bonsoir à tous
est ce que moi je vais le faire en
français parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
des gens un peu différent dans
l'audience dont commandement des mois de
faire en français mais est-ce que déjà
vous êtes au tac
alors ça ça me va pas vous vous levez
levez-vous parce que normalement on se
lève tôt au tac s'il vous plaît levé
vous mais je vais pas commencer tant que
vous n'êtes pas levée donc même le vieux
monsieur avec la can devant on se lève
merci beaucoup alors on lève le poing
droit pour que vous taquet à troyes 1 2
3 hautacam quand même au taquet faut y
aller avec la voix même les english
alinghi je pouvais dire ailleurs si vous
préférez n'y a pas de souci alors à 2,3
au taquet c'est bon on peut commencer
c'est parfait nick et à l'homme donc moi
je vais vous parler en fait j'ai juste
faire un petit partage de trucs un peu
débile des trucs qui sont un peu à
contre courant que que moi je fais mais
à nouveau
c'est quelque chose je veux dire c 'est
pas comme m'a dit mon coeur ça tue pas
des poneys c'est vraiment un truc easy
donc je vous explique le truc vous
regardez puis à prendre ce qui pourrait
potentiellement vous intéresser donc
dans mon cas un mois en fait j'ai
commencé une boîte alors que je bossais
dans une autre boîte donc c'est dans une
autre boite je bosse c'est tranquille le
ch attaque machin qui joue un concept
aux états unis qui était cool
alors j'écris aux américains jeudi
américain ça vous tente de lancer ça en
suisse puis en europe ils me font rire
story mais l'europe ce n'est pas un pays
que nous combattons je suis ok
l'europe n'est pas en payer les gars
c'est un groupe de pays dits jamais et
tout ça c'est pas grave ça nous
intéresse pas donc je vous dis bon ben
ok on va démarrer la combine
et puis je lance jean ce truc qui pour
relancer strübin je fais un pari avec un
prof de marketing où je lui dis bah
écoute mon gars moi ce que je veux c'est
long c'est une boîte mais avec pas un
rond en poche
et puis aller à contre courant de ce que
tu m'as appris donc pas de truc
marketing à la con qu'on nous enseigne
aux cours pendant des années vous n'êtes
pas retirer quelque chose avec un angle
qui est complètement différent donc du
coup pas je lance jean cela combine
machin pains francs en poche je
m'associe avec la femme du boss de la
boîte dans laquelle joie c'est qu'ils
m'aident pour tout l'aspect un peu plus
structuré comptables et autres et puis
ce départ je commence laventure donc
le truc démarre et ce qui est hyper
intéressant c'est quand vous démarrez
une petite combine comme ça ben vous
avez des gens ont fait autour de vous
qui vous font ça n'a jamais marché tend
pas un sou en poche tu fais pas de
marketing
tu connais personne bla bla bla bla là
je me suis dit mais moi je veux
commencer un truc avec mourir mon réseau
en fait mon réseau de postes soit g50
paul je leur envoie un mail
et puis vont aller sur mon site parce
que grosso modo j'ai un site internet
qui vont des produits chaque jour en
ligne à partir de minuit avec un beau un
fort concept communautaire qui jouaient
dimanche je vais lancer la la combine
pilote du mef
en plus le nom de ton site c'est coca
comme la commune célèbre boisson
apparemment et puis on me dit mais là tu
vas te ramasser une pêche dans la
tronche ça va pas le faire et tout cet
été complètement cramé puis je faisais
avant mais c'est bon on y va quoi je
toute façon je le papier de mon job
qu'est ce que je risque pas grand chose
donc pas violence la combine tac ma
chance a démarré tous les ip 10 puis
tout d'un coup bas je peux après une
année je me rends compte que ça prend un
petit peu on engage une nana machin qui
à faire logistique on était dans le
garage justement de la femme de mon boss
cave aussi un petit quart note c'est la
côte est donc une fois qu'on avait fini
les bouteilles de rouge horaire on a
déménagé dans le carnotzet donc on avait
le garage plus le carnotzet peu près bon
bah quand on était 4 5 6 au bout de
trois au bentalha il faut grandir un
petit peu donc on était serrés dans le
carnotzet je pense que s'il y avait eu
la section du travail à l'époque
j'aurais pu faire mais ma boîte voyez
des fois il faut un petit peu aller au
dessus de tout ça puis bon on fonce puis
cinq ans après ben moi je décide de
quitter mon diop il mettra 100 % pour ma
boîte parce qu'on était déjà sept
personnes et puis laventure des mavs
et puis dans ce que je veux vous dire
par rapport à ça c'est qu'en fait vous
avez beaucoup de gens autour de vous qui
peut vous dire écoutes oublie ça n'a pas
marché machette ou s'ils ont là vous
pouvez écouter ce qu'ils vous disent
d'une oreille selon moi mais ça peut
vous motiver moi ça m'a chauffé que mon
prof de marketing douai tu vas te
planter ça va être la merde en plus de
ça tu vas de chopin procès machin moi
j'ai adoré ça je me suis dit ça va être
les meubles si ça marche ça va être méga
drôle puis un coup de bol de fil en
aiguille ben ça a plus ou moins
fonctionné puis aujourd'hui ça fait dix
ans que
depuis le premier jour où j'ai commencé
que la boîte tourne sentiments donc
voilà c'est pour vous expliquer un petit
peu comment j'ai on peut démarrer un peu
une boîte de manière un petit peu décalé
sont trop ce focus et sûre sur les on
dit qu'on nous dit surtout en europe en
suisse on nous on essaie de décourager
pas mal mais dans mon cas à moi ça m'a
plus boosté puis je vous encourage tous
est entrepreneur j'applique vous
souhaitez vous lancer à faire tout péter
quoi puis les gaillards qui sont à côté
de vous puis qui vous disent ah ouais
attention l'aspect légal mais envoyait
les p&t puis foncé quoi je dis pas qu'il
faut être complètement hermétique puis
pas écouter ce qu'on vous dit puis quand
on vous met des alertes il faut voilà
c'est mon conseil à moins il vaut ce
qu'il vaut je dire moi je suis personne
vous dit juste que moi j'ai vécu
puis commence à fonctionner après moi
j'ai l'impression que d'avoir un peu
dans vie ben ça ça aide pas mal pour les
troubles donc voila un petit peu le la
première combine que je voulais vous
expliquer qu'il était la slide l'angle
après ben je vais vous parler de sortir
des sentiers battus pour moi c'est
extrêmement important alors là je vous
parle vraiment plus comment
d'entrepreneuriat au quotidien toi parce
que vous lancez même si voulons c'est un
truc hyper sérieux
en suisse on a les avocats il avocats
n'ont pas le droit de faire de pub que
les médecins mash-ups les sortez des
sentiers battus on dit soulagé que tout
faire tout péter donc sortir des
sentiers battus ça veut dire quoi c'est
pas dire qu'ils vont pas respecter une
certaine ligne ça veut dire qu'il faut
être différent pour qu'on attire le
regard sur vous toutes et vous allez
venir pas fonds chez lui ça n'arrête pas
mal quoi parce que vous êtes différent
c'est ce qu'on vous appelle les us paie
là je crois à l'école à l'oeil et unique
selling proposition ou je sais pas quoi
moi ça c'est leur langage leur jargon
eux mais en réalité ce qu'il faut c'est
vraiment que vous soyez différents avis
que vous puissiez prendre quelque chose
de un petit peu à contre courant donc
pour moi ceci sa part du bon sens
profond que pouvait avoir
et puis du fun que vous pouvez mettre
dans votre job même si c'est un job
hypercard et vous pourrez avoir du fun
dans ce que vous faites
moi je me lève le matin je peux vous
dire c'est juste l'émeute quoi je me dis
aujourd'hui je sais pas ce qu'on va
faire
peut-être qu'on va aller se faire un vol
en montgolfière peut-être que je sais
pas moi jamais employé qui va ce million
de choses qui va se passer c'est ça qui
fait vibrer et c'est ça que j'aimerais
vraiment vous transmettre un petit peu
aujourd'hui
après dance est clair quel côté d'être
disruptif vous voyez je vous donne un
exemple assez assez cool
un jour c'est une anecdote que je
raconte parce que je la trouve assez fun
quoi j'ai raconté déjà quelques fois
mais moi je fais tellement poil et un
jour je vais et puis je vends sur notre
site un site pendant un disque de zone
bleue qui tourne tout seul vous ai déjà
vu que ton ce parc chez nous en suisse
on dormait des 10 de zone bleue et puis
ben il faut le mettre à telle heure et
puis on a une heure une heure et demie
de parcage puis après ben et à la
contractuelle qui se pointe pays pauvres
qui vous colle une amende ben moi
j'évolue indices zone bleue qui tourne
tout seul vous met une petite pile de
doxa êtes jamais en retard comme on ne
peut jamais vous coller une amende donc
imaginer la combinaison fouta sur le
site ça fait le carton plein machin 9h30
je reçois un appel de quelqu'un d'une
police dont je tairai le nom une dame
qui m'appelle une charmante voix qu'elle
dit bonjour alors hein c'est madame pas
eu de l'office du stationnement deux
bibles je venais non parce que mais
alors écoutez monsieur ça vous allait
retirer de la vente immédiatement se
disent zone bleue qui n'a pas conformes
et qui tourne tout seul alors qu'elle
commence à remonter un peu le ton quoi
je joue le jeu c'est la merde pas eu
elle n'est pas contente on peut faire
quoi loger d'écouté blâme pas eu je vous
rappelle laissez-moi 5 mi temps que je
raccroche puisqu'il veut que la prise ou
qu'on retire le truc quoi comment on
fait je réfléchis je me dis mais non en
fait c'est tout con en fait chier sur le
site puis j'ai nommé le produit en
horloge en forme du double qui tourne
tout seul puis terminer jeudi
du coup j'ai rappelé même pas au gie
vous avez raison madame pas eu on a
retiré un truc c'est plus un 10-2 11
blocs comme ça c'est une horloge
donc du coup on peut être plus dont elle
n'a même pas eu donc du coup ça fait de
l'épreuve puisque ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que parfois soyez créatifs on
peut trouver notre chemin pour passer du
point a au point b
il faut le faire quoi il faut essayer il
faut être disruptif il faut faire des
trucs de barjots et puis épi fort du fun
quoi enfin moi c'est vraiment le truc
que j'ai envie de vous dire mais bien
sûr ça peut paraître bateau l'espèce de
guignol devant vous qu'elle est en train
de vous causer
même moi c'est vraiment ce que j'ai vu
au quotidien puis c'est clair on tape
des bons à perroncel et bonne bouffe
comme aujourd'hui à midi c'est cool mais
l'idée derrière c'est aussi l'heure du
plaisir dans ce que vous faites si c'est
quelque chose de sérieux que je peux
vous dire que par exemple les
conseillers que nous on a par contre
l'avocat ou autres qui sont des membres
fidèles de notre communauté des caucase
mais il s'éclate avec nous ils se
marrent quant aux messieurs vous êtes
complètement barjo quand on reçoit une
lettre
de grands fabricants de téléphones avec
une pomme dessus qui vous écris ça vous
fait marrer vous captez que dalle fait
un langage d'avocats et twitpic
enfin voila moi je vous encourage
vraiment aller au dessus de tout ça
c'est clair que pour moi un des éléments
importants
c'est à y ait du plaisir dans ce que
vous faites quand vous êtes entrepreneur
c'est en suisse au gabon ou bien je sais
pas où et y ait du plaisir dans ce que
vous faites vous si vous et du plaisir
vous serez petit fois plus performant
tout cas moi je peux vous dire que au
quotidien bassesse ouais c'est un
plaisir c'est vraiment un plaisir
donc j'ai passé en fait la suite avec
quelque chose ou parfois en fait en
ayant du plaisir ça peut se retourner
contre vous puis je vous montre en fait
une petite vidéo qui illustre en fait un
gag que j'ai voulu faire le 1er avril
2014 puis qu'il s'est un petit peu
retourné contre moi mais je vous le
montre et puis on en discute après ian
ziering
le choix du cygne de new wave et tout un
fautif
soit le qf chaque prof de batterie basse
et lifesize bah moi je vais vous faire
une table quand on a fait cette vidéo
mais j'étais chaud bouillant re étape un
bon apéro donc on t'attend appel vous ne
seront plus créatif tout cas chez nous
et puis bon dans cette vidéo est tout
machin on foule truc en vente sur le
site
il a un minutes passées commencent à
minuit chez nous de minuit à 00h10 le
serveurs saturés machin et tout donc au
final je vous la faire courte on à 1200
personnes qui ont acheté le new world
fund 2014 donc mes collègues m'ont dit
arrête tout mon coeur
arrête stop stop toute la combine machin
tu te rappeler qu'il faut qu on va faire
comment j'ai dû trouver 2400 boîtes de
conserve exactement identique
donc imaginez vous le merdique c'est un
truc incroyable incroyable
bon finalement y arriver on a fait un
truc super drôle les gens sont éclatés
enfin bref on a conservé son bien mais
c'est pour vous dire que des fois force
de jouer aux guignols ça peut se
retourner contre vous piquante soudé ça
dans la phase bas il faut assumer et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est
effectivement très important maintenant
moi j'ai trois éléments pour moi qui
sont juste essentiel c'est le fait
d'avoir confiance pour moi quand vous
lancez votre projet c'est extrêmement
important que vous ayez confiance en
vous quoi sérieux pas moi je vous dis ça
c'est un petit truc que je partage avec
vous mais qui me concerne moi mais je
suis sûr que c'est applicable pour vous
aussi
ayez confiance en votre projet si vous
avez confiance en votre projet vous
allez pouvoir faire des trucs de barjots
le deuxième truc pour moi qui est
important c'est de faire confiance
faites confiance délégué aujourd'hui
j'ai une équipe qui ont attaqué on est
40 personnes a bossé sur les 40
personnes il y en a trente neuf qui sont
aka pire
guignol devant vous maintenant mais les
39 autres c'est des gens qui sont ces
des perles quoi me fait des shows qui
croyant la même cause que vous donc fait
confiance aux gens qui vont travailler
avec vous et n'ayez pas peur de faire
confiance pour moi c'est un élément qui
est important est le troisième point qui
pour moi est juste est essentielle mais
donner confiance vous faites un truc moi
je vends des entrepreneurs ils ont un
super projet machins sont des artistes
ils se lancent ils ont confiance en eux
ils font confiance à un ou deux gars
puis tout d'un coup il ya une question
qui répondent pas mais l'image que vous
devez donner c'est une image de
confiance
vous êtes là vous voyez quelqu'un qui
est qui qui a lancé sa boîte vous poser
une question vous devez vous devez avoir
du répondant vous devez être fiable pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
c'est de fait habilité que vous devez
avoir et en fait finalement le dessin de
ce que vous allez de ce que vous allez
de l'image que vous allez projeté donc
soyez fiable très important pour moi ces
trois points sont justes essentiel
courant son projet faire confiance et
surtout avoir cette fiabilité donner
confiance en ce que ce que vous faites
donc voila moi je ne vais pas vous aider
à dépasser mon temps je vais pas
m'attarder plus longtemps ce que je veux
juste vous dire en résumé pour moi c'est
oser tout donner être fiable et puis
surtout au taquet 1 2 3 ôta cal a encore
une fois vous êtes vraiment mou là je
dirais à genève aujourd'hui 1 2 3
ça fait plaisir merci beaucoup